Linden is in Boston Massachusetts hey
Linden how are you hey Dave thanks for
taking my call
sure how can I help yes I just have a
quick question right now on baby step
two and I want to buy a single-family
home on 25% take on pay and my wife she
wants to buy a duplex with 25% of
take-home pay on earth side of rent and
rent the other side to her parents I
just want to know what your thoughts on
that
well number one we don't buy a house and
baby step two you're talking about I
hope after baby step three right yeah
like in the future okay cool all right
well duplexes are an interesting thing
too if you're going to live in half of
it the good news is your renters live
next door the bad news is your renters
let you live next door and of course
when you get ready to resell a duplex
someday your resale market is primarily
a real estate investor that's going to
buy it and they generally are looking
for a bargain so a 2,000 square foot
duplex next door to a 2,000 square foot
single-family typically does not
appreciate as rapidly because the
single-family has a retail market
available to it on resale the duplex has
a wholesale market that's not to say
they're bad that's just some of the
limitations add into that equation you
got you're going to move your
parents-in-law in the next door and
you're going to charge them rent this
sounds like a chemistry for an explosion
to me number one you're charging your
mother-in-law rent number two if she
doesn't pay or something breaks and
number three they live next door there's
a lot of possible relational nightmares
here yeah I mean I agree with you I
wanted to buy a single-family home on
the 15th you know and she just wants to
help her mom out
you know she's you know you know you
know she's getting old she you know she
came from Cambodia's you children or
anything about investing [ __ ] I would
I would rather give her mother money
than do this okay to help her if she
needs help with her rent or something
somewhere and you not be the landlord
because I'm just telling you man if
something breaks over there and you
don't fix it to suit them you've got a
tenant problem and you've got a
mother-in-law problem you following me
okay yeah I just I mean some families
can make this stuff work but most
families can't and so it's um you know
and it's not a good long-term plan
because you're you're just asking for
relational chemistry explosions I mean
it can happen you people do it and it's
not a let's say you're doing something
wrong if you do it on but I think
there's probably other ways to help her
mom rather than you buy all of your
housing arrangements around her and then
expect her to pay um he that just sounds
like because I mean what happens the
first time she stubs her toe and doesn't
want to pay well now you've got a house
payment that's 50% of your take-home pay
because you told me you wanted to set up
half of it on 25 mama gets sick and mama
can't work well we got to take care of
mama weekend a victor right I mean it'd
be hard to evict a tenant period that
was sick but if it's mama
you're not a victim her oh women you do
when you get foreclosed on because your
house payment is now 50% of your
take-home pay because you entered into a
screwy idea so yeah I can back I'm gonna
back up I'm going to just say this is a
dumb idea I wouldn't do it I might buy
duplex but I wouldn't move my
mother-in-law in next door to me I think
that's a problem I think you're going to
get you I think there's more downside
than upside here I think there's other
ways to help her I would buy if you're
going to buy duplex have a traditional
tenant next to you or buy a home one of
the two and either one of those is fine
but I just and again I'm not I'm not
passing judgment on your mother-in-law I
just think there's all kinds of downside
here that I'm just not I don't think
there's wisdom and entering into it hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
[Music]
Oh